welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for a presentation titled
characterization and selection of
antibodies for precision diagnostics
using via core surface plasmin resonance
technology
it's my pleasure to introduce you to
anya drescher senior application
specialist for biacore systems saitiva
for a complete biography on our speaker
please visit the tab at the top of your
screen
now if any questions arise during the
presentation we encourage you to submit
them into the q a box our speaker will
address your questions following the end
of the presentation
please join me in welcoming anya
drescher i will now turn the
presentation over to her
welcome anya
thanks for joining and welcome to my
talk about the characterization and
selection of antibodies or other
proteins for precision diagnostics using
biacore sbr technology
for all precision diagnostic essays
you see here just some examples
defined detector molecules are needed
nato provides us with numerous examples
of such detectors like cell surface
receptors that binds hormones or growth
factors
all the well-known antibodies you see
here each of them recognizing individual
antigens which can range from tumor
markers to virus spike proteins
the proper selection of such binding
molecules allows you to develop
sensitive and selective diagnostic
assays even for use with very complex
biological samples
for a successful diagnostic essay the
detector molecule must fulfill certain
biophysical characteristics
which are very individual for biological
molecules and can't be theoretically
predicted they need to be measured
the detailed analysis of binding
properties and behavior of the detector
molecule
can guide your selection and support the
quality control over the complete
lifespan of a diagnostic assay
what are these characteristics of a
perfect detector molecule
first of all the detector needs to be
specific for an individual
binding site on the respective analyte
to not cross-react with other molecules
in your sample
a very stable complex should be formed
because the signal will last longer and
such complexes will be resistant to
washing steps in the essay
a fast binding is advantages
since it allows short incubation times
for the essay
and finally the binding of a perfect
detector should be insensitive to
various reduction conditions
which questions need to be answered
during the detector selection process
first of all define what should be
detected
are there may be special details for the
analyte known you need to take care of
what kind of sample will the essay face
is there a potential sample matrix
interference on the binding reaction
what is the necessary sensitivity and
specificity
which diagnostic essay format is planned
since you might need antibodies which
recognize different epitopes on the
antigen in question
which temperature range the sa will face
during storage or when the analysis is
performed
and how stable is the detector molecule
activity during production purification
and storage
if you can measure
the lot to lot variability of the
detector activity you can adjust the
concentration applied in your assay
production accordingly
all of these questions on the
characteristics of a perfect detector
molecule can be answered with biacore
spr systems
biological interactions are real-time
binding events where molecules associate
with
or dissociate from each other
biacore systems enable real-time
label-free monitoring of these
biological interactions
what are the benefits of biacore sbr
systems
they employ a label-free detection
system so no labels are required and
therefore they can measure binding
properties of unmodified substances
resulting in save of time and workload
on sample preparation
vehicle systems measure in real time so
you can observe binding as it happens
and this provides
unique information on binding rates
as association and dissociation rates
are time dependent processes they can be
only determined with a real-time
analysis
in addition
real-time analysis allows observation of
transiently existing complexes
as well as stable ones
systems have a contact-free detection
system which means the detecting light
beam does not pass through the sample
so direct measurements of opac or
colored samples with loss of sensitive
without loss of sensitivity and accuracy
are possible and you can work with crude
samples like serum or cell extracts
b ecosystems have three core components
for detection of molecule interactions
in real time
so first the sensor chip which is a
variable part depending on the
application that should be investigated
and this sensor chip is inserted to the
biacore instrument
they have a microfluidic system for
automated handling of low sample volumes
and
a surface plasmon resonance detection
unit
the so-called sensogram depicts the
binding response observed over time
one interaction partner which we call
the ligand is attached to the sensor
surface chip inserted to the biaco
instrument buffer is flowing over that
surface giving us a baseline response
the sample containing the other
interaction partner the so-called
analyte
is passing over that surface and if
binding occurs the mass on the surface
increases which will be recognized by a
increase in response of the sbr
detection
signal
here this system switches back to buffer
passing over the surface and you can
then observe how fast the complexes
which have been formed how they decay
from the surface
there are several readouts possible from
bioco essays
specificity how specific is the
interaction for one or the other analyte
which you will recognize if there is a
binding response or not
concentration
how much of a given molecule is active
because only the functional molecules
show the respective binding
and binding kinetics can be determined
how fast or slow does the complex form
or decay
such a kinetic characterization of
biological interactions can guide the
selection of best-in-class detector
molecule
how does this work
we see here an overlay of two
interactions showing the same steady
state affinity but significantly
different kinetic rate constants
which you can recognize from the
sensogram shape
so here
you see
a fast association for this interaction
and also a fast
dissociation so these complexes decay
quite fast
direction here shows the flow
slower association but the complexes
when they have formed they show a very
stable
complex which decays very slow
you see it here in the slope
of the
sensogram
in your selection process for the best
in class detector molecules you should
aim for a fast association rate
because then in your essay you can allow
short incubation times
and with a fast association rate you
would also have the advantage that
binding occurs already at lower sample
concentrations
but even more important is that that you
aim for a slow dissociation rate because
this means the complexes which are
formed
are very stable the slower the
dissociation rate the more stable are
the complexes
and such stable complexes will withstand
several washing steps and incubation
times in the run of your essay
i will now present some case studies
which demonstrate how biacore spr
analysis was applied for detector
molecule selection
first of all a screening and
characterization of antibodies for use
with diagnostic devices which is a
collaboration with biomedical
diagnostics institute at dublin city
university in ireland
bdi develops next generation biomedical
point-of-care diagnostic devices
high-quality antibodies or antibody
fragments are key components used in
their diagnostic essays
they have screened diverse antibody
libraries
directed against kinetically relevant
biomarkers of cardiovascular disease or
cancer with aim of the biacore
instruments
here you see an overview of bdi
screening workflow
they employ phage display to screen
their single chain antibody fragment
libraries
vdi has an automated primary screening
process but the results of this initial
screen are of limited data quality
so with further detailed analysis was
essential to identify good lead
candidates for single chain antibody
fragments which will be taken further in
the development step
for that purpose they screened their
single chain antibody fragments with a
biacore assay
to speed up the analysis all single
chain fragments were fused to an
hemoglotinine antigen attack
an
anti-hemoglotinin antibody was
immobilized on their surface
and so
the single chain fragments with the h8
tag shown here in red so single chain
fragments are in blue here this is the
tech they could be captured directly
from crude cell lysates on the surface
on the
h a antibody
so different single chain fragments
could be uh analyzed in each sa cycle so
in in the used system
eight different single chain fragments
were screen per essay cycle
and always one concentration of the
troponin was passed over the samples and
then kinetics were investigated
and in this screen
well plates of single chain fragments
specific to human cardiac troponin 1
were screened
here you see the raw data the results
they got from the screen of all these
single chain fragments
this is an overlay of all sense
sensograms from each of the clones
investigated
in one picture and they were focusing
for for the ranking of these clones
based on the complex stability so they
mainly looked here in the this is on the
dissociation phase and they took report
points early in the dissociation and
after one minute which you see here
and the risk the difference of these two
responses were used to calculate the
percent left amount
and this number
indic allows a fast
selection of the most stable complexes
as you see here in this sensogram there
are some which show a very stable
binding so there's almost no signal
difference between these two
report points here
and there are others like this one which
decay very fast so there will be a huge
difference in these
report points taken
so this is a very fast and easy
identification possible for clones which
show the most stable binding
the result overview overviews easily
can easily be seen in such a plot where
the the early response
put here on the y-axis and the later
response after one minute of
dissociation is plotted in this
direction so
this line here shows 100 percent left so
it means there was no signal drop
over the run of this one minute
and the clones which
are located here close to the hundred
percent left line are the most
interesting ones because they are the
best binders showing the most stable
complexes
in this essay
they have run 960 samples within eight
hours
and the data all the results could be
evaluated in less than two hours
the most stable signal chain fragments
were then rapidly identified and used
for further prioritization
so top ten percent were taken for an
additional kinetic characterization
because what they aim for is to get the
best in class binders which show
also a very stable complex formation at
physiological temperatures
so for this
purpose they investigated kinetic rate
constants at 25 degree which would be
similar to what they have done in the
screening
and they measured the same interaction
at 37 degree shown here
and
this is one of the best in class single
chain fragments which retained a quite
stable
complex formation so a slow dissociation
also at physiological 37 degrees celsius
so a temperature stable high affinity
single chain could be quickly identified
for further testing in bdi's diagnostic
device platform
the next study looks at the impact on
the biochemical environment on detector
molecule binding
this is a collaboration with scott
clarcamp and andy drake from upgenex and
david mishka
theorists of this study asked the
question
does the binding of detector antibodies
tolerate varying buffer conditions and
to answer this
they investigated the binding behavior
under variable salt and ph conditions
and
they employed such as such an essay set
up
so four different antibodies were
immobilized here in one flow cell
and the same set of antibodies also here
in these others so they had four
four flow cell with four different
antibodies and over each flow cell the
antigen diluted in a buffer with
different conditions was
passing over that surface so they could
investigate
four different buffer conditions at a
time
you see here the results of the antibody
binding under various salt conditions in
the buffer
so here the kinetics of all these four
antibodies was investigated with buffers
containing 50 millimolar sodium chloride
up to 600 millimolar sodium chloride and
the affinity change was observed
three of these antibodies
showed
sequentially lowered affinity
just the monoclonal antibody 12 was
almost unaffected by changes in salt
concentration
and here are the combined results for
salt and ph effects
on the binding of the four investigated
antibodies
this plot shows here the determined rate
constants association rate and
dissociation rate for each of the
measurements under the eight
and the eight different
running conditions
and
just monit the monoclonal antibody 12
shown here with the pink circle
showed the least buffer sensitive
binding
and this antibody was then taken for
further
investigating in the diagnostic device
now i will show you how epitope binning
analysis can be used for further
differentiation of diagnostic reagents
for the development of a diagnostic
sandwich assay like the one shown here
you need to identify antibody pairs
which recognize non-overlapping epitopes
on the antigen to be determined
otherwise they cannot bind to the
antigen at the same time but this is a
prerequisite for setting up such type of
essays
the binding characteristics to be
screened for
have to be the same as for all perfect
detectors
epitope binning experiments with beer
core need minimal time to results
especially when using predefined capture
formats
for this purpose beerco offers
ready-to-use capture kits for antibodies
from different species like mouse or
human
we provide pre-established assay methods
for large number of pairwise antibody
testing
that guarantees a fast learning curve
also for new
users the sensor chip surfaces thereby
can be used multiple times which lowers
the running cost for such an assay
and the antibodies investigated can be
applied directly from hybridoma
supernatants
so there is no risk of damage during
purification and a shorter time to
decision
which
allows
less budget spent on keeping unnecessary
clones and culture
the setup looks like this the capture
antibody from our capture kits is
immobilized on the surface or you can
even use pre-immobilized ones
the first antibody from your pair is
captured here on the surface the other
binding site is blocked and then the
antigen is injected binding here to the
first antibody
the second antibody can only bind when
it shows when it when it shows a binding
when it reacts with another epitope on
this antigen
then the whole complex is removed and
you have a free surface again to inject
the next antibody pair which should be
investigated
and you can observe
all these interactions in the
corresponding sensogram so first you
have the baseline here then you have the
injection of the first antibody blocking
antigen and second antibody and for each
of these interaction you can also
observe if they are less
or
very stable
in addition to the predefined methods we
offer an intuitive software for
streamlined evaluation support of
epitope binning data
this software runs on our most actual
high throughput instrument platforms
like biocore 8k plus biocore 8k and also
the data from biocore t200 can be
investigated in this software
here you see the most important
evaluation items for an epitope winning
experiment
so this here is the sensogram overlay of
all interactions binding of the second
antibody
and here you can set cut-off lines very
easily just by moving them so it's a
very interactive tool and from from
these results here the so-called heat
map will be generated indicating
the antibodies which recognize the same
epitope here indicated in red and the
ones which
will recognize different epitopes
and from these results the binning wheel
is created
which indicates the relation and
connection of all identified bins on the
investigated antigen
now i will show you how beer core can be
used for quantification of binding
activity
and the first example you will see how a
direct determination of active protein
concentration in complex samples like
plasma could look
like the default essay format for
diagnostics using bio systems is in most
cases a direct binding essay
so here you see the detector antibody
immobilized on the sensor chip surface
the sample containing the analyte is
passing over that surface
and binding to the detector can then be
measured
here you see the principle of a biocore
concentration analysis in real time
this is the essay design so on the
sensor chip
the detector antibody is immobilized on
a three-dimensional dextran matrix
this is chosen because
also if immobilized the antibody
molecule remains flexible on this deck
strain and we have a three-dimensional
surface so the capacity here for
detector antibodies is much higher
this will lead to a
much more sensitive
detection range
the sample is passing over that surface
and only the antigens which are
recognized here by these antibodies
gives a response because only they bind
to the surface
you see here the corresponding
sensograms from a constant from a
calibration curve
so here
this this is an overlay of the the
different concentrations injected here
with increasing concentration the signal
increases and here these complexes which
are formed are very stable
to get rid of them because we want
always to reuse the surface
the samples are regenerated with a ph
high ph or high salt shift
and the complexes are opened and the
sensograms are done
back to baseline so we have an empty
surface again
so what you see here are increasing
concentrations and then for each
concentration the report point the
response is taken at the defined time
point
and this response is then plotted
against the given concentration of the
standard and you get here these standard
curves
an unknown sample
is the responses measured from the
sensorgram at the same time like for the
standard and this response then tells us
with the calibration curve how much
concentration is in that sample
as an exemplary quantification
i chose this biocore igg subclass
distribution essay which was designed
for a human igg production process
when igg used for intravenous
administration the igg subclass
distribution needs to be determined
in this essay
on the four flow cells of a biocor t200
system
antibodies recognizing the different
subtypes like itt1 igg2 igg3
were immobilized
and the diluted
plasma sample was passing over all flow
cell cells in a row so giving
four different concentration results
in one them from one sample injection
this table depicts the standard which
was used and uh this
showed uh the same distribution as it
would be
expected in human igd
in typical human igg
here you see the standard curves for
each idg subclass obtained
simultaneously with the different
detectors immobilized here on the
different flow cells
these are overlays of the sensograms for
the different
calibration concentration
and the report points here
are taken to create
the calibration curves depicted here
concentration against relative response
and you see some of the
this interaction here is very very
stable over the whole run of the
experiment so you see all calibrations
curve for more or less exactly
overlaying
for other
detectors
their stability is not that well as this
one
so you see a drop in activity with
lowering signals in the calibration
curves over the run of the analysis
but this is no problem for biocore data
evaluation software as it can compensate
for these effects
for very stable assays like the total
igg concentration determined here
the detectors show a high level of asset
stability and robustness
so as you see here this is total igg
determination and these are the standard
curves
over the run of the essay and also
measured
at different
time days so day one day five and day
nine
and you see they're almost overlapping
they're all run on the same surface and
still no activity loss can be observed
so such an excellent essay stability
enabled the use of a master standard
curve and results for the production
could be observed at line in less than
10 minutes per sample
here you see how thousand cycle runs
are looking in one plot combined
together
the red dots here are the calibration
curves over the run of these experiments
the green are the controls and the blue
are the samples which have been measured
and you see the samples and when it's a
repeated sample it was had a cv of 1.3
percent over these thousand cycle runs
so when when you are lucky and you have
a very stable detector and a properly
established assay you can use it for
very long time it's very cost efficient
and
finally i show you this bureaucra essay
for quantitation of influenza virus here
an inhibition format was used
for such an essay
the respective influenza hemoglobin
protein was immobilized on the sensor
surface
in the sample a defined concentration of
the detector molecule which is here an
anti-ha antibody
is pre-incubated with the sample
if there's a low number of virus
particles
a high concentration of detector
molecules
is still present in the sample and they
are able to bind to the surface giving a
high response
when a high number a high virus theta is
present in your sample most of the
detector molecules are bound to the
virus particles and just a few can bind
to the sensor surface giving resulting
just in a very low response
and this is how such typical sensor
grams look like so you see here the
sensogram in red there's just a very low
amount of virus standard
so
there's a lot of detector molecule
binding to the surface and when you
increase the virus theta you
get most of the detector molecules bind
to the virus and just a low response
signal is observed a typical inhibition
essay
here you see a combined assay to
quantify three flu viral strains at a
time represented in a vaccine dose
so the setup was as follows you have one
empty flow cell for control
and then on this on these three flow
cells the different
viral strain antigens were immobilized
the virus sample
the vaccine sample was then passed over
all flow cells in a raw and you got
these inhibition curves for the
standards in parallel
the interesting of this
essay was that the the vaccine producing
company initially
just measured concentration of the
different strains in their vaccine with
an srid
assay shown here with the red bars
this line here indicates the essential
concentration which should be included
in the vaccine dose
and indicated in blue here these are the
results of the biacore measurement and
you can see that for the strain b
the vaccine dose was significantly
overfilled
and
by knowing this then later on this
company could save a lot of this
recombinant material
and
more doses could be
produced with the same amount
of vaccine
with the first part of my talk i
hopefully convinced you that biacore spr
analysis is a valuable tool on the
selection of detectors for diagnostic
assays
a fast and reliable selection of
detector molecules which show exactly
the kinetic behavior
which is advantages for your diagnostics
is possible with biocore assays
you can determine the specificity and
epitope recognition on the antigen to be
diagnosed
it is also possible to predict
robustness of the detector binding over
a range of environmental conditions and
in complex samples
observing the active concentration of
your detector molecule with the biocore
assay during production purification and
storage
allows you to define protein
concentration needed for diagnostic
assay production
resulting in lower lot to lot
variability
so you can optimize process and storage
conditions for your respective detector
antibody
generally just one interaction essay
needs to be established for all
analytics
on an individual detector molecule
in the second part of my talk you have
seen examples verbiacore sbr analysis
was employed as a direct diagnostic tool
to save asset time and sample material
a direct and specific analysis with low
amounts of complex samples is possible
because biacore microfluidics allow
working with low sample volumes to save
rare liquids like patient or animal
serum
several interactions can be observed
simultaneously with the identical sample
saving sample material and essay
preparation time
taking into account the higher
reproducibility
less hands-on time less hands-on and
essay time of a biocore analysis it is
significantly advantageous over the
broadly employed elisa format essays
so i hope you agree with me that biacore
instruments provide a versatile
multifunctional analytical tool to
assist your selection of the perfect
detector molecule
or to make use of biocore instruments to
run directly automatic diagnostic essays
with this i will end my presentation
and thank the audience for your kind
attention
thank you anya for that excellent
presentation we will now move into the
live q a portion of our presentation
as a reminder to our audience please
submit your questions via the q a box
okay anya
our first question is let's see we have
some great questions coming in
let's start with this one
to determine antibody concentration
i use
od 280 and hplc via protein a affinity
column
what is the advantage of using the bio
core system
yeah so thanks this is a good question
because what's typically done is to
determine concentration of iggs via
protein a columns because it tells us
how much
active and functional
antibodies are in the solution but this
is just determine binding
via the fc part
the huge advantage which you could have
in addition to such a measurement which
you could also do in a biocore essay
you can immobilize the respective
antigen of the antibody so such a
binding will show you
how um
what what the real activity what you
would need for your further as a
development and to observe the stability
of your antibodies as this is something
which is the individual
function of of the respective antibody
you will investigate
and in our systems as you have seen the
presentation before you will be able to
measure for example the binding of the
fc part look how much properly folded
antibodies are in your sample solution
and on another flow cell determine the
antigen binding activity which is often
much more sensitive also than the fc
part which is the most stable part of an
antibody so
this um
the antigen binding is what you're
really interested
um when you look at
storage conditions or
stability
during purification or whatever else
could be interesting also then how it
works in your
future essay
thank you
now anya an example from biomedical
diagnostics institute you show eight
different
scfe
fragments screened per assay cycle
how many parameters or reagent
candidates can be tested in parallel
oh this is also a good question so in
our typical
biacore 8 play instruments you can
always
run
eight different single chain fragments
tested in parallel so you can capture
them eight different and then run your
sample over them
and i have once
did
a calculation for an hda screening
for a customer of mine and
so
here we we calculated that for example
when to screen to
348
plates with with clone extracts um but
that what they get from their phage
display
um when you just capture it for one
minute and then do a screen as i had
showed the similar one with one antigen
concentration such a measurement can be
done
without any hands-on
and it will run 20 hours
if you do the same screening
um
with capture and then directly look for
kinetics of these fragments then with
three concentration and the single cycle
screen you could
get these results in 27 hours and then
it's very easy
to evaluate them so it's really a
possibility already for your initial
screen directly from the extract to run
it in vehicle systems
excellent now next question it's a few
parts so bear with me here
i develop lateral flow assays kits the
membranes often contain or require
antiotic suffectants to help make the
membrane hydrophilic and help proteins
bind to the membrane
however
surfactants denature proteins and can
destroy the antigen binding sites of
some monoclonals
making them non-usable in a lateral flow
assay
being able to identify candidates that
exhibit this behavior early is therefore
an advantage
can biacore be used to screen detergents
surfactants and to monitor impact on
antibody and antigen binding
oh thanks for this question yeah this is
really uh interesting and uh we have the
possibility so similar to what what i
showed in the presentation where they uh
measured binding under different ph and
soul concentration just by changing the
running buffer we also have an
opportunity
in our beer core 8k systems and also in
vehicle s200 to test um a lot of
different conditions um for for the
binding itself so
um we have a functionality which is
called aba
where you
can inject the sample under
significantly different conditions so
the sample injection which comes to your
binding will be can be
designed under different soul different
detergent as you would be interesting
and so by this you can
in a predefined method you can test up
to 96
different conditions in one run
and look how it will influence the
specific binding so this is a very easy
way if if if you want to get information
on this
test the binding as the functionality of
your antibody with the antigen which
should be tested in your lateral flow
essay and
then just vary the condition whatever
additives you need to test
you can add them and then
observe how they influence if they
influence at all
this specific antibody you aim for or
then you could
look for
set the conditions you want to have for
example in your running buff already and
then do the screening of your antibodies
under such conditions so then you can
directly identify which might be the
ones which
will work later on in your test kit
great thank you anya
now a time for
maybe two more questions but i do want
to remind our audience that any
questions we are unable to answer during
our live event today they will be
answered via email following the live
presentation
okay let's
let's go with this one which sample
volumes do you need for an analysis
oh
yeah this is a good question and maybe
also in comparison
to other essays very interesting
so um as an example for where i showed
the
analysis in the biacore t200
for such a concentration measurement you
will need
40 to 80 microliter of your sample
for for
one to five minutes injection
and
it doesn't matter if you just
investigate this one analysis or if you
directly investigate
four different interactions as
if the sample passes over all surfaces
will be the identical solution and
giving you one or up to four different
interaction results
great and anya let's wrap with this
question
isn't there a risk of clogging of this
microfluidic system when working with
crude sample extracts or plasma
this is an understandable um
yeah problem
you might think of but
we really have a lot of experience with
handling samples
these complex samples like plasma and
all our instruments have predefined
maintenance procedures already
programmed in the instrument control
software which
reminds you
that that they need to have a cleaning
and so this is all predefined protocols
and in addition for handling samples for
example we have also a lot of lab guys
and protocols so we have
experienced
with what are the right washing
solutions
to be um
when when you're working with sticky
samples like like plasma and you can get
all these protocols so just contact us
we will we were really happy to support
you
in this handling and
this is nothing you need to fear of um
there have been really a lot of these
studies done there's also already
published results on this and
we can guarantee that um you will make
it and don't need to worry
thank you anya
now it does look like we are out of time
but i want to tell our audience to not
worry any of those questions that were
submitted that we were not able to
answer today and we'll be addressing
them via email anya thank you again for
your time today and thank you to the
audience for your great questions
today's presentation will be available
for on-demand viewing for 12 months so
please remember to share this with your
colleagues who may be interested in
today's topic
and don't miss out on the other
presentations on our agenda visit the
agenda tab in the auditorium for a full
listing
thank you again for your participation
and until next time have a great day bye